we have today a second story that serves
as a really good case study and the
propaganda cycles that are often started
by President Trump but then perpetuated
by Fox News which gets them into the
ecosystem and generates these default
reflexive talking points that we end up
hearing for years from the Trump astride
despite being completely wrong and free
of any facts and I'm gonna explain this
entire thing to you we actually have a
couple of propaganda cycle stories for
you today there is a White House
national security official named
Alexander vind Minh Binh Minh is a
whistleblower ving Minh says he heard
the phone call where Donald Trump pushed
the Ukrainian president to investigate
Trump's political opponents like Joe
Biden how VIN Minh is set to testify
before Congress which is going to be
extraordinarily explosive testimony we
are talking about
Lieutenant Colonel Alexander VIN Minh a
Vetter a vet 'add that is national
security official a military veteran and
Donald Trump has previously suggested
that whistleblowers the people going to
the whistleblowers with information that
they are basically spies and Donald
Trump alluded to treason he alluded to
the execution of such treasonous spies
and last night on Fox News's Laura
Ingraham program a real doozy of a show
it was suggested that what Alexander
vind Minh did is espionage and that VIN
Minh might even be I hope you're sitting
for this one
a Ukrainian double agent check this out
and pay attention to whether you
recognize the person making this
argument this is buried in the New York
Times piece tonight but I found it very
interesting he's a decorated colonel by
the way in the Iraq war but because
Colonel Vin de Minh emigrated from
Ukraine along with his family when he
was a child and his fluent in Ukrainian
and Russian Ukrainian officials sought
advice from him about how to deal with
mr. Giuliani though they typically
communicated in English now wait a
second John here we have a you
with national security official who is
advising Ukraine while working inside
the White House apparently against the
president's interest and usually they
spoke in English isn't that kind of an
interesting angle on this story
I find that astounding and you know some
people might call that espionage but it
doesn't actually seem to add any new
facts to what we know if you know in
terms of I think Alan raises a good
point is this a high crime a misdemeanor
whether you have one person or five
people all saying well we objected to
what the president said with the
president of Ukraine we have the
transcript of the call we can all make
our judgment I don't see how this
breaking news actually adds more facts
what we know about whether this is an
impeachable offense or not so if the guy
suggesting this looks familiar that's
John you he's the guy who imploded when
questioned by the late John Conyers when
asked whether he thinks that legally the
president could have a suspect buried
alive and he does one of the greatest
lawyer non answers maybe in
congressional testimony history where he
says I've never recommended to a
president that they have a suspect
buried alive
no no but but counselor you could the
president do that I don't know why any
president would ever do that I know lots
of presidents no president would do that
this it for the young people in our
audience we're taking a brief departure
from the whistleblower thing this is a
classic clip of Bush administration
lawyer John you check it out is there
anything miss professor you that the
president could not order to be done to
a suspect if he believed it necessary
for national defense well during I think
that goes back to the quote you just
read because no I'm just asking you the
question may be of those that doesn't
but what do you think I think it's the
same question that I was asked or what's
there's such time I made clear I'm not
talking about new
to make anything clear just answer the
question of counsel I just want to make
sure I'm not saying you don't have to
worry about that saying just answer the
question okay my thinking right now yes
right now am I thinking right now this
moment this moment mr. chairman is that
you know first the question you're
posing what is the answer
it was try not trying to make you know
you're wasting my counsel I practice law
:
could the president order a suspect
buried alive mr. chairman I don't think
that I have ever I'm asking you that
given the advice that the president
could bury somebody alive I didn't ask
you if you ever gave him advice I asked
you do you think the president could
order a suspect buried alive mr.
chairman
in my view right now is that I don't
think a president would and no American
president would ever order that or feel
it necessary to order that yeah so that
guy thinks that the whistleblower might
be a spy Ukrainian double agent last
week I had a caller who said wait David
I thought Republicans were for military
veterans
I thought they supported the troops and
I explained to you that's only true when
it serves their political goals here's a
military veteran who they are smearing
as a spy because it doesn't serve their
political goals to say hey you know what
we respect the troops we support the
troops and if this guy is a veteran of
the American military then maybe we
should listen to what he has to say now
this may deliberately or accidentally
get Lieutenant Colonel VIN Minh killed
this is serious stuff or they are doing
okay when you have someone that Donald
Trump who is looked up to as a deity by
trumpets say the whistleblowers may be
spies or treasonous that's already
endangering their lives when you then
perpetuate the propaganda on the echo
chamber that is Fox News with John you
saying this guy could be a double agent
this guy could be working for Ukraine
you are literally endangering this man's
life now they are now as predicted
shifting to attacking the whistleblower
and the whistleblowers character to get
their base fired up and to shift the
focus off of what Trump did to how we
found out about it this is a very common
tactic that to be perfectly frank is
often employed by the left and the right
when you have a leak or a whistle being
blown if you like the content you focus
on the content if you don't you focus on
how we found out about it and isn't it
terrible how this information went
public that the left and right does this
vin Minh importantly though is blowing
the whistle to protect our country
against Donald Trump who is putting our
national security at risk our
sovereignty at risk and the way that
this fits into the propaganda cycle is
that the trumpets will chug this
nonsense like it's being ladle fed to
them and it will become the go-to
talking point the whistleblower you're
talking about the spy Ukrainian double
agent who is a treasonous whatever
charge him right away really dangerous
times that we're living in and this one
is really simple to understand espionage
has a very specific definition
politically spying to obtain political
and military information well what do we
mean by spying is just hearing something
spying
no spying is work for a government or
organization done by secretly collecting
information about enemies or competitors
lieutenant-colonel vin Minh works for
the US and blew the whistle in the u.s.
because he's worried about how Donald
Trump is hurting the u.s. that's not
espionage that's not treason it's none
of the above it's really important we
understand it because they are putting
people's
at risk